écoutez on est forcément satisfait
d'être élu un homme heureux
quelle conclusion on peut tirer de ces
résultats en loire atlantique
mais écoutez le travail a pu payer
puisque je pense que les sénateurs
sortants avaient fait du travail avaient
assuré leur mission pleinement et je
grands électeurs l'ont reconnue par par
leur vote
on voit que plusieurs d'entre nous
sommes des élus sortants
il ya un seul nouveau dans la danse être
élections donc je crois que c'est aussi
le fruit de notre engagement et de notre
passion pour la fonction sénatoriale qui
est la nôtre je pense que c'est une très
bonne chose pour l'équilibré des
pouvoirs entre l'assemblée nationale et
le sénat
on a vu une vague de nouveaux qui sont
rentrés à l'assemblée nationale nous
assigne à tort je pense qu'on va
apporter cette expérience des
collectivités territoriales il faut pas
oublier que dans la constitution sous
l'article 24
il est prévu les marques et que nous
étions avant tout les représentations
représentants des collectivités
territoriales et c'est ce dont nous
faisons la preuve aujourd'hui avec des
élections qui tienne compte finalement
de cette proximité que nous avons avec
le terrain avec les élus locaux avec
ceux qui nous ont vus régulièrement près
d'eux et qu'ils nous témoignent par leur
vote
la candidate de la république en marche
ici dans le département n'a pas réussi à
transformer l'essai des élections
législatives quelles leçons peut en
currie ici bas la leçon qu'en plus on en
tirer c'est que c'est encore une fois
important d'avoir des élus locaux qu'ils
soient devant d'autres élus reconnu
comme tel nous nous étions une liste de
sept mers pour la loire atlantique la
personne qui était qui représentait la
liste en marche est une élue
d'opposition dans une collectivité qui
n'a aucune aucun pouvoir exécutif qui
n'a aucune expérience dans l'exercice
des responsabilités locales
je crois que nos grands électeurs ne s'y
sont pas trompés avant tout ce que l'on
veut c'est des gens d'expérience à des
gens qui ont prouvé leur compétence en
étant régulièrement réélu ce qui est mon
cas et ceux qui étaient avec moi dans ma
vie